la primera prueba de fuego para la paz
el presidente colombiano gustavo petro
se movilizó hasta la ciudad de neiva en
el centro del país para condenar el
atentado donde murieron siete policías
siendo una zona tradicionalmente marcada
por la historia de la farc
es altísimamente probable
e integrantes que llaman hoy disidentes
en algunas de las formaciones
haya sido responsable el atentado
la mayoría de las víctimas eran
auxiliares de policía jóvenes que no
portan armas y realizan trabajos
comunitarios sus familiares no
encuentran consuelo
yo nunca
pensé que mi niño pronto dio esta es una
noticia que no lo quisiera que nunca
llegará
y desafortunadamente infortunadamente
hoy toca el corazón de la familia
es un muchacho un hijo que se nos va
por esta desgracia de violencia que
tenemos nosotros en colombia petro un
antiguo guerrillero ha llamado a
negociar a los grupos armados que aún
operan en colombia todavía ninguno se
atribuye la autoría del ataque en lo que
va del año unos 30 policías han sido
asesinados y la organización indepaz
lleva registro de 74 masacres 13
ocurridas desde la llegada de petro al
poder